[Música]
y hoy en directo a vamos a Venezuela
porque hay expectativa después de que el
presidente de colombiano Gustavo Petro
propusiera una Cumbre internacional
sobre Venezuela que se llevará a cabo en
Bogotá la próxima semana con miras a
desatascar el proceso de negociaciones
entre el gobierno y la oposición
venezolanas además el mandatario dijo
que las sanciones impuestas a Venezuela
por Estados Unidos eran temas central
durante su encuentro con Joe biden este
21 de abril conectamos con Daniela
Zambrano corresponsal de France
veinticuatro en Caracas Daniela es
viable este levantamiento de sanciones
que propone Petro que reacciones hay en
la capital venezolana
Hola qué tal para poner en contexto la
audiencia es importante recordar que el
pasado primero de marzo la propia
administración
estadounidense prorrogó el decreto que
mantiene a Venezuela o califica
Venezuela como una amenaza para la
seguridad estadounidense y su política
exterior precisamente del decreto que
permite aplicar sanciones a países en
determinadas circunstancias y
recientemente también un portavoz de la
Casa Blanca advirtió que Estados Unidos
se reservaba el derecho de endurecer las
sanciones en caso de que hubiese más
represión contra los opositores que haya
incumplimiento de los acuerdos por parte
de Nicolás maduro por lo que no parece
tan viable que se puedan levantar las
sanciones en su totalidad tal y como lo
ha solicitado en múltiples oportunidades
Nicolás maduro y su gobierno una de las
primeras reacciones que ha habido a
través de las redes sociales a esta
propuesta del presidente colombiano
Gustavo Petro ha sido por parte del
dirigente opositor Juan guaidó quien
decía que eliminar las sanciones la
posibilidad de llegar a un acuerdo y le
da un cheque en blanco al gobierno
Nicolás Maduro para seguir violando
derechos humanos decía para que hubiese
cero sanciones en Venezuela tenía que
haber cien por ciento democracia y el
hecho de que no había democracia era las
razones por las cuales había sanciones
sin embargo También es importante
destacar que Estados Unidos decidió
flexibilizar las sanciones impuestas a
la estatal petrolera para que Chevron
pudiera explotar petróleo en Venezuela
porque tenía intereses económicos al
respecto otro tema que centra la
atención en estos momentos es la Cumbre
internacional sobre Venezuela que se
llevará a cabo en Bogotá la próxima
semana qué se espera de este encuentro y
quiénes van a participar
lo que se ha anunciado por parte del
gobierno colombiano es que cerca de 15
países van a participar con
representación de ministros y
cancilleres entre los que se conocen
hasta el momento estaría por parte de la
Unión Europea España estaría también
Francia Alemania por América Latina
Argentina Ecuador Brasil Canadá se había
especulado si Estados Unidos iba a
participar o no era uno de los invitados
en más temprano el presidente Gustavo
Petro desde Nueva York dijo que estaba
entre los países invitados y se esperaba
su presencia en esta Cumbre que se va a
realizar el próximo 25 de abril
inicialmente el propósito era destrabar
el diálogo entre la oposición y el
gobierno venezolano que recordemos ha
estado estancado desde que se acordó que
se liberaran unos fondos que estaban
bloqueados en el extranjero para que el
gobierno los pudiese invertir en materia
social el gobierno condicionó que
continuará el diálogo a que sus fondos
fueran liberados Y esto no ha ocurrido
hasta el momento uno de los principales
en reaccionar ha sido el propio
presidente Nicolás Maduro que han dado
que ha dado su total respaldo a este
próximo encuentro dijo que deseaba que
fuera exitoso pero a través de un
comunicado de la cancillería advertía
que la única forma de continuar con los
diálogos en Venezuela era precisamente
que se levantaran las sanciones